IBM research has helped catalyze some of
the biggest accomplishments in Computing
and artificial intelligence history so
uh D blue
uh IBM D blue versus Kasparov chess
match in 96 and 97. uh just just to ask
kind of like what your perception is
what your memory is of it what is what
is that Moment Like This seminal moment
I believe probably one of the greatest
moments in AI history when the machine
first beat a human at a thing that
humans do you you make a very
interesting point because it is like one
of the first demonstrations of using a
game to like bring something to people's
Consciousness right and and to this date
people use games right to demonstrate
different things
um but at the time
funny and didn't necessarily think of it
so much as Ai and I'll tell you why I
was and I'm not a chess player you might
be a chess player so I'm not expert at
it but I think I understand properly of
Chess that chess has got a finite number
of moves that can be made
therefore if it's finite really what's a
demonstration of a super Computing right
it's about the amount of time and how
fast it can crunch through to find the
right move so in some ways I thought of
it as almost a bigger demonstration of
that but it is absolutely as you said it
it is was a motivator one of the big
Milestones of AI because it put in your
Consciousness that it's man
in this per in this other machine right
yeah I'm doing something so you saw it
as just a challenging competition
problem and this is a way to demonstrate
hardware and software computation at its
best yes I did but the thing is there is
a romantic notion that chess is the
embodiment of human intellect I mean
intelligence that you can't build the
machine that can beat a chess champion
in chess and the the fact that it's
possessed by not being a chess expert so
it wasn't like it's just a computation
problem it's a computation problem to me
well that's probably required to not be
paralyzed by the immensity of the task
yeah so that this is just solvable but
it was a very very I think that was a
powerful moment so speaking just as an
AI person that was uh
that uh reinvigorated the dream you were
a little kid back then though right at
95 you have to be like were you uh you
remember it actually at the moment yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what did you think
at the moment about it
um
it was
awe-inspiring because
um especially sort of growing up in the
Soviet Union
you think especially of Gary Kasparov
and chess like your intuition is weak
about those things I didn't see it as
computation I thought of it as um
uh intelligence because
chess for a human being doesn't feel
like computation yeah it it feels like
some complicated uh relationship between
memory and patterns and intuition and
guts and Instinct and all of those like
something you watch someone play that's
what you have to conclude right and so
to see a machine be able to uh beat a
human I mean you get a little bit of
that with chagi PT now it's like
language was to us humans the thing that
we kind of uh surely the The Poetry of
language is something only humans can
really have it's going to be very
difficult to replicate the magic of a
natural language without deeply
understanding language but it seems like
Chad GPT is can do some incredible
things with language and uh um in uh in
natural language dialogue so but that
was the first moment in AI through all
the AI Winters from the 60s is the
promise of the it was it was wow this
this is possible for um
for for a simple set of algorithms to
accomplish something that we think of as
intelligence so that I that was truly
inspiring that maybe intelligence maybe
the human mind is just algorithms that
was the thought at the at the time and
of course now what the the funny thing
what happens is the moment you
accomplish it everyone says oh it's just
Brute Force algorithms it's silly
um and this continues at every single
time you pass a benchmark a threshold to
win a game people say oh well it's just
this it's just this it's just this and
that that
um I think that's funny and there's
going to be a moment when we're gonna
going to have to contend with AI systems
that
exhibit human-like emotions and feelings
and you have to start to have some
difficult discussions about well how do
we treat those beings and what role do
they have in society what are the rules
around that you know and this is really
exciting because that also puts a mirror
to ourselves to see okay what's the
right
way to to treat each other as human
beings because it's a it's a good test
for that it is because I always say it's
a um a reflection of humanity what a I
mean it's taught by what man you know
that stuff in the past you'll teach it
bad stuff for the future and which is
why I think you know like efforts to
regulate it are fools here and you need
to regulate uses not you know because
it's not the technology itself is not
inherently good or bad but how it's used
or taught can be good or bad for sure
right and so
um that's to me will unveil now a whole
different way of having to look at
technology uh what about another magical
leap with the early days of Watson with
beating the Jeopardy challenge what was
your experience like with Watson what's
your vision for Watson in general yeah
and it was really inspired by first
chess right and Casper off and then you
come forward in time and you know I
think what Watson did because you used a
really important word AI had kind of
waxed and waned in these winners right
in and out in and out popular not more
money less money you know in and out
confidence no confidence and so I think
that was one of the first times it
brought to the Forefront of people like
oh I could humanized it because here it
is playing against these two gentlemen
and as you did lose it first you know
and then finally finally one at the end
of the day and but what it was doing is
making you say hey natural language it's
actually understanding natural language
it's one of the first demonstrations of
natural language support and bit of
reasoning over lots of data right and so
that it could have access to a lot of
things come up with a conclusion on it
and to me that was a a really big moment
and I do think it brought to the
conscious of the public and in good ways
and bad because it probably set
expectations very high of like whoa what
this could be but and I still do believe
that it has got the ability to change
and help us man make better decisions
that so many decisions are not optimal
in this world you know even medical
decisions and it's right or wrong what
took us down a path of Health Care First
with our Ai and and we took many pivots
and I think there's a really valuable
lesson in what we learned one is that
actually I don't think the challenges
are the technology yes those are
challenges but the challenges are the
people technology are the people
challenges around this right so do
people trust it
how will they use it I mean I saw that
straight up with with doctors and like
meaning they're so busy in the way
they've been taught to do something
do they really have time to learn
another way I saw it was a mistake when
you put it on top of processes it didn't
change kind of like Paving a cow path
didn't work I mean it was all human
change management around it that were
really its biggest challenges and
another valuable lesson we picked back
to usage you think of IBM as moonshots
we picked really hard problems to start
with I think you see a lot of Technology
now starts with really simple problems
and and by that it probably starts to
build trust because I start little it's
like oh I'm not ready to you know
Outsource my diagnosis to you but I'll
get some information here about a test
question so very different thinking so a
lot of things to learn we were making a
market at the time and when you make a
market you know choice of problem you
work on gets to be very important when
you're catching up well then it's a
scale game so very different thing and
so but why it's improved I think I mean
I hope I'm not being too
um
I think Watson brought AI back out a
winner for the world and that since then
there's just been you know one company
after another in Innovations and people
working on it and I have no regrets of
anything that we did we learned so much
and we probably rebuilt it many times
over it made it more modular and today
tybm a Watson is more about AI inside of
a lot of things if you think of it that
way which is more like an ingredient
versus it's a thing in and of itself and
I think that's how it'll bring its real
value you know more as an ingredient and
it's so badly needed and even back then
the issue was so much data like what do
you ever do it you can't get through it
you can't use it for anything you know
this well it's your profession so
um
we have to have it so that's a that's
going to propel it forward so it's part
of The Suite of tools that you use when
you go to Enterprise and you try to
solve yeah so problems AI for security
Ai and automated operations AI in your
robotics AI on your factory you know I
mean it's it's all part of and I think
and that's why even to this day
thousands I mean thousands and thousands
of clients of IBM still have the Watson
components that it's the AI being used
so it became a platform is how I would
say it right
um and an ingredient and that went
inside and Consultants like you said had
to learn
I had they had to learn
don't just put it on something you got
to rethink how that thing should work
because with the AI it could work
entirely differently and so I also felt
it could open up and still will open up
jobs to a lot of people because more
like an assistant and it could help me
be qualified to do something and we we
even years ago saw this with the French
banks very unionized but that idea that
you could in this case the unions voted
for it because it felt people did a
better job and so and that's this part
about being really dedicated to help it
help Humanity not destroy it